okay so look Dragon Ball super is over
okay okay I get it but hey look I'm here
kind of the sort sort of well look I'm
here now and doing novelty acts no less
remember that video I did like a year
ago when they reviewed like half of
Dragon Ball super in ten words or less
well let's finish off beating that dead
horse to death cuz why not write
diminishing returns be damned if you
haven't seen part 1 of this video then
I'm impressed I have no idea how you
managed to thread that needle but you
might want to get on that before
watching this video so the same rules
apply as last time I will be reviewing
episode 77 through to 131 in 10 words or
less while giving them each a score from
minus 10 all the way up to 10 the
negative scores are for those episodes
that are so bad they're good
so really the closer it is to a flat 0
the worse it is are you guys ready let's
do that openly not literally though ok
if you're not sold on the tournament
idea here's another tale as old as time
and if these guys are brothers what
happened to lavender so the trick was to
hit him really hard the award for best
moustache in the universe goes to this
episode is immediately a winner because
of this shot power level triggering
aside this is a pretty fun episode what
is even happening anymore
go home Tori I'm a you're drunk arguably
one of the prettiest fights in all of
super wishing for a boat regular Dragon
Balls can do that a lot of rehashing
dialogue decent episode nothing special
I love how tiens not the focus of his
episode nice visuals but it's too little
too late for Gohan what boo fell asleep
where have I seen that before
I can't believe they actually had it
freezer - the team I can't believe they
actually had it freezer - the team how
do you spell freezer bada s s freezer I
literally couldn't ask for more than
this episode thanks a distinct lack of
peel off gang this arc good finally it's
felt like we've waited 20 episodes oh
wait
talk about all dogs go to heaven huh no
okay 43 minutes remain in the torta oh
there goes curling this is my OC you do
not steal board of the Iranian No
give it time hey look it's rip rayon
everyone's favorite character look at
this photograph every time I stand it's
God Toyama can we still use Super Saiyan
God genuinely one of the best monologues
in super bike right worst Tournament
episode so far forward
who'd have thought Roshi vs Frost would
have been so amazing freezes the best
character in the sack like no question
breaking news local man throwing spear
pond becomes very upset according to
sources he is literally too angry to die
interesting matchup but it was
eliminated way too early
I've got a question does anyone besides
Vegeta like Kaaba though complain the
teacher role is both fresh and fun
holy Takahashi on a tricycle this
artwork is awesome alright reawakening
ultra instinct is pretty fun to see
contains my favorite piece of fight
choreography in Dragon Ball it was in
this episode the internet collectively
rejoiced hmm really enjoyed what they
did with the namekian fight soon
is how piccolo goes out bad character
portrayal boring episode that really
only serves as a setup weird is
definitely better than boring but still
a great brilliant characterization
phenomenal artwork and animation one of
the best Super Saiyan blue evolution
sounds dumb looks cool though is it bad
that I laughed while Frieza
eliminated Gohan once again Frieza
demonstrates why he's my number one bad
boy my favorite part was when VG's big
ball hit top O's this sort of a set up
episode but how the tension well if
we're being honest we all saw this one
coming could be a contender for best
transformation in the series better
action and animation than any Dragon
Ball episode ever
and finally I'm probably gonna get [ __ ]
for this but [ __ ] the most satisfying
conclusion and greatest episode I've
ever seen now hold your horses I ain't
done yet seeing as I've reviewed the
entire series from start to finish in
ten words or less it means I can share
with you my five favorite and least
favorite episodes from the entire series
so let's begin I'm gonna be honest
making a list of the best episodes was
incredibly difficult in the entire
series there are so many great episodes
that picking only five is incredibly
hard so tough in fact that I had to
decide whether or not I should include
122 as being worthy of this spot over 47
but ultimately I had to make a choice
and I went with episode 47 please don't
shoot me while episode 122 looked
spectacular and was itself a great
episode what 47 meant for the franchise
was huge this was the episode that told
the world super is here and is [ __ ]
great
all the while introduced into the
community a new character whose impact
in the series would only be matched by
its impact on deviantART on a different
day I might argue that 122 is better but
right now I cannot deny the significance
this episode played during supers run
back in the day you know those episodes
that are purely fast and can be cut out
without any meaningful loss to the story
well this abomination isn't that because
it includes a major elimination piccolo
so there's no way you can skip this one
it's a gimmick filled mess of an episode
with an elimination that feels really
undeserved and completely out of
character for piccolo episodes 93 and 94
laid the groundwork for this spectacular
installment one that became the sole
reason I was in any way excited to see
the tournament of power and that reason
can be summed up in one word Frieza 93
and 94 tell the story of freezes
recruitment and passage to earth but
episode 95 hit like a jackhammer when it
dropped the evil Emperor letting us all
know that he is in no uncertain terms
still as murderous and vengeful as ever
even going as far as to slaughter
hundreds of assassins and attempting to
strike a deal with universe 9 right
after you know putting Goku in a ball
it's a long story
Frieza was the wild card that made this
entire arc interesting with the added
element of unpredictability I don't
think there's any way around saying this
but this episode was really boring the
novelty of there being a quote sniper
character lost its charm and intrigue
almost immediately on top of that it
further served to demonstrate the fall
and insignificance of tension on which
we didn't need to say it ends with
tension on eliminating himself so as to
eliminate another character sinfully
dull disappointing an overall pointless
some of you out there might think I'm
cheating with this one but screw you
this was a one-hour special so it counts
and this whole installment was quite
simply fun pure fun it is exactly what
Dragonball should be the focus of the
episode was the show Goku's first fight
with jiren testing his strength before
ultimately unveiling to the world the
brand new transformation ultra instinct
which looks fantastic
as time has pushed on and I've seen the
series more and more one episode almost
sticks out from the first arc as the
most boring and pointless episode four
five might get a lot of flack for its
animation but at the very least
something happens in that episode to
hold our interest the majority of this
episode is pure filler aside from a
scene here and there you could skip the
entire episode and not miss a thing no
shadow of a joke I have probably seen
this episode about 30 or 40 times if you
could all just take a minute of silence
for my socialite taking a break from the
Goku Vegeta fight scenes taking place we
catch up with Android 17 and the star of
the episode Frieza bring dirty tactics
and a sadistic attitude to every fight
he's a part of in this episode Frieza
eventually struggles against the newly
anointed god of destruction topo who
leaves Frieza at the end of the episode
on a figurative and very literal
cliffhanger I present to you the single
most pointless capable episode in the
entire series episode 30 taking place
immediately before the universe 6
Tournament episode 30 takes 20 minutes
to remind us about the first two arcs we
just saw which were themselves recaps of
the movies we all saw it's clear that
this episode exists entirely to give the
production team more time and that's
totally understandable but the episode
still sucks I've always been a guy more
interested in the story consequences of
an episode than the actual fighting
itself and while I adored episode 130 s
non-stop action episode 130 gave me
everything I wanted in an episode and so
so much more I could speak for hours
about every aspect of the episode from
the perfect characterization to the
impeccable storyboarding the stunning
animation or even the perfect escalation
of tension leading to the end of the
tournament it was an episode that
reminded me how big Dragon Ball is but
how it can even now make me feel like I
did when I was a kid watching the show
back
the day please enjoy an audio
representation of how I feel exactly
about this episode and yeah that's about
the size of it
you